we have a follow-up now on our eight
news now investigators in-depth look at
a courtroom designed to clean up the
strip repeat visitors to this criminal
courtroom the so-called Resort Corridor
court is just one tactic Clark County
officials plan to use to fight High
numbers of arrest on the Strip eight
news now investigator Kyle Payne joining
us in studio tonight with more Denise
last night we took a good look inside
this new courtroom which opened in
January we met the judge what I like to
call the strip Court it took a lot of
planning and maneuvering for the county
to get that Court going and they're
likely not stopping there you will be
given a map you must stay out of those
areas those areas you
around and on the strip
recently overrun with crime
violent crime according to retired Las
Vegas Metro Lieutenant Ted Snodgrass
any kind of violent crime you could
think of specifically Violet crime in uh
against the person robberies homicides
uh um assaults shootings visitors in
December 38.8 million and that's why the
Clark County Commission Drew this map
around this trip case is dismissed and
told this judge to keep the constant
troublemakers out do you think that a
ban will help
well I think it I think it can help I
don't think it's a solution but I think
it can be a part of the solution to the
crime that we're experiencing on Las
Vegas Boulevard
and on the boulevard Snodgrass says
simple fixes like signs that say you're
not allowed to smoke dope or drones to
monitor those scoff laws they're trying
to keep away from the so-called Resort
Corridor in order for it to be
successful it can't just all be the
place you have to have a concerted
effort appointing the public defender's
office to represent you Gibson says the
judge is only part of the solution he
said the county also needs to make sure
make sure that the D.A and the public
defender have are able to take care of
their responsibilities there
before the court opened one single
conviction wouldn't necessarily have
gotten you banned from the strip one
person we profiled last night had three
dozen arrests you can watch that part of
the story on eightnewsnow.com